so Sky News has once again teamed up
with YouGov to find out about public
attitudes to the government's handling
of coronavirus and if we start here all
the way along through the first few
months of the corona virus pandemic the
public gave strong backing to Boris
Johnson's government in March and April
even as we were going into lockdown this
white line here which is how well the
government's doing was high 72 percent
of people said they were doing well and
it peaked 21% badly but as lockdowns
being eased you can see that that line
has crossed over and now as the
restrictions start to come off July the
fourth obviously going to be a big day
you can see that the government is still
in negative territory for its handling
of coronavirus and on Thursday this week
the polling we did suggests that 51% of
the population think the government is
doing badly and 44% think it is doing
well so why is that well we dug down
into exactly why people think what they
do and if you look at different aspects
of the government's handling of
coronavirus you can see that there
broadly supportive of what the
government did to protect the economy
and job 65% saying they did well
protecting people in work and protecting
the economy is 54% but that critical
figure has the government managed to
minimize deaths while only 30 percent of
people thought they did well at that and
those things that the government was
specifically responsible for testing and
tracing distributing protective
equipment to those on the front line
while 23% and 28% respectively so only a
minority of the public thinking that
they did a good job at that meanwhile
the public seemed to have a more
favorable view of the labor leaders
handling of the pandemic kist honor of
course not being in post at the start
but coming in a few weeks after the
corona virus pandemic hit badly and here
we have 42 percent of the public saying
he's been doing a good job on
coronavirus 22 percent saying that he's
done a bad job and 36 percent saying
they don't know so if the government are
overall in negative territory I suspect
the kissed
we'll be quite happy to have more people
saying he's doing a good job than a bad
job now why is that what absolutely
fascinating is we are has Kirsten have
been too supportive of the government on
Cove aid 19 and only five percent
thought that he had backed Boris Johnson
and the government too much nineteen
percent thought that he had been too
opposed to the government and 44 percent
thought that he had done about right now
kiss Dharma has negotiated quite a
careful line targeting some narrow
elements for criticism but backing the
broad thrust of the government's
approach including last Tuesday's lock
down lifting announcement and it looks
from this polling as if the public think
that was the right decision